on a park bench in Porter Prince a
couple shares a tender moment wildly
incongruous with Haiti's escalating
chaos right here I was attacked
um
in October 2020 with law Marin Corps a
Porto Prince editor-in-chief in charge
of 20 journalists
Ralph cynical runs an ambulance service
he has done so for almost three decades
this October he was kidnapped they won
one million dollars from the U.S
that was the acting price Ralph had
dropped off a dialysis patient it was a
long journey as he drove back into the
capital he was taken 17 days 17 days
with my hand Thai with my shoelaces so
he began the nightmare which in Haiti is
shockingly no longer shocking Haiti is
in the midst of an extraordinary
security crisis the United Nations
estimates that 60 of the capital is
controlled by gangs gangs that murder
and rape and burn and kidnap their
threat is felt across the city and
beyond
faith helps many here
a crowded church on Sunday morning
two Services back to back such is the
calling
widlaw's calling has been high impact
journalism today he banters with a
colleague but eight fellow Haitian
journalists have been killed so far this
year he is being treated for PTSD I
can't help but feel lucky because
I know so many people who did not have
the chance to survive
events like this and be able to tell
that story the UN says 540 people were
kidnapped and more than 700 killed by
The Gangs just in the first five months
of this year Ralph's family paid more
than 200 000 US dollars to his captors
and if your family had not have paid you
will kill me
is that what they said no yes that's
what that's what they do more than a
year after Haiti's president was
assassinated the streets of Porto Prince
have become a lottery of survival
through the one Al Jazeera Porto Prince